Godzilla is arguably as most terrifying
ever in minus one with a heat ray that
detonates like a nuclear warhead and a
roar that follows every brutal attack
Godzilla doesn't just seem angry at
Humanity he seems angry at simply being
alive it's a rage that reflects koichi's
own survivors guilt a feeling of
discomfort with the gift of life it's
not just the atomic bomb that has
summoned the monster in this version of
the story but the combined grief anger
violence and shame that those who
escaped the war left with defeating
Godzilla means putting those things to
rest and finally choosing to live for
the future that's why the former
soldiers need the younger generation to
help them win in the end and it's the
reason that the true victory for kichi
means surviving his final attack